.
Schau, dort ist ein Pelikan.
Er sitzt dort oben.
- Oh, ja, dort ist auch noch einer.
Komm, Papa, gib Vollgas.
Halt dich gut fest.
- Festhalten.
Hui!
Juhu! Oh, fliegt dein Hut weg?
Für mich ist es wirklich genau das,
was wir gesucht haben:
Meer, Sonne und Freiheit.
Es ist wirklich herrlich.
Lily Rose,
setz die Sonnenbrille auf.
Vom St. Galler Rheintal nach Florida
zieht es Familie Tscharner.
Am Golf von Mexiko
wollen sie Ferienhäuser vermieten.
* Eines der Kinder
plappert unverständlich. *
Zuerst aber müssen sie renovieren.
Igitt, eher nicht.
- Die Küche muss man rausreissen.
Es ist nur aufgeklebt.
Fast am Polarkreis
liegt das neue Zuhause von
Isabelle Schelling und Steff Felix.
In Island suchen sie mehr Freiheit.
Komm, gib mir dein T-Shirt.
Er reizt alles aus, was möglich ist.
* Sie lacht. *
Auf ihrem riesigen Grundstück
wollen sie Tiny-Häuser bauen.
In diesem Bereich
kommt ein Kamin hin.
Wir stellen sie einfach dort hin,
wo es uns gefällt.
Ich bin so stolz auf dich, Schatz.
- Danke.
Otmar Gemperli
und sein Partner Gabor Balogh
übernehmen auf der spanischen
Ferieninsel Mallorca ein Restaurant.
Hier gibt es extrem viel Arbeit.
Ab jetzt haben wir geöffnet.
Die Gäste können kommen.
Eine turbulente Zeit beginnt.
Jetzt siehst du, wie viel Schaum es
ist. Bis hier kommt das Bier. Warte!
Wow!
- Guten Appetit.
# Uf u dervo, yeah.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Ein traumhafter Blick
ins St. Galler Rheintal.
Das Eigenheim
mit grossem Garten und Swimmingpool.
Familie Tscharner hat das,
wofür sie viele beneiden.
Okay, willst du das anziehen?
- Ja.
Trotzdem zieht es sie weg.
So ...
Jetzt gehen wir runter.
Seit acht Jahren träumen Melanie
und ihr Mann Mario vom Auswandern.
So, Frühstück.
- Papa!
Wow, du bist aber eine Hübsche.
Na? Wow!
Komm, wir frühstücken.
Schau mal hier, das Frühstück.
Wir müssen schon bald los.
Ihr Sehnsuchtsort: die USA.
Mir wurde das von meinen Eltern
in die Wiege gelegt:
ein Amerika-Fan zu sein,
eine Faszination für dieses Land
und seine Menschen zu haben.
Hinzu kommt die Musik. Meine Mama
war ein totaler Elvis-Fan.
Deshalb habe ich das Gefühl,
als würde ich
zu meinen Wurzeln zurückkehren.
Ich bereite mal das Auto vor.
Kommst du mit, Lily Rose?- Ja!
Du auch, Ruby?
- Mal schauen, ob er noch läuft.
Auch Mario
ist vom Amerika-Virus infiziert.
Bei ihm begann alles mit alten Autos.
Achtung.
Mit seinem Oldsmobile 98 hat er sich
ein wenig vom amerikanischen
Lebensgefühl in die Garage geholt.
Am liebsten würde ich ihn mitnehmen.
Ich hänge schon an ihm.
Wir haben schon viel zusammen erlebt
und er gehört schon fast
zum Inventar bzw. zur Familie.
So.
Nicht nur das Oldsmobile
steht jetzt zum Verkauf.
Auch von ihrem Haus sowie
allen Möbeln wollen sie sich trennen.
* Dynamische Countryrock-Klänge *
Hast du die Vignette angebracht?
Ja, die Vignette ist dran.
* Dynamische Countryrock-Klänge *
Melanie und Mario fahren mit ihren
Kindern zu einem US-Car-Treffen:
ein letztes Mal.
Die Veranstaltung
ist ein Mekka für Amerika-Fans
und für Liebhaber
von blitzendem Chrom und Stahl.
Wow, schau mal, der ist cool.
Man schiebt alles nach hinten,
schliesst den Kofferraum
und dann sieht man
das Dach nicht mehr.
Das ist schon ein nettes Wägelchen.
Anstatt in Oldtimer investieren sie
ihr Geld zukünftig in Immobilien.
In Florida haben sie
bereits zwei Häuser gekauft.
Diese wollen sie renovieren,
neu ausstatten und an Feriengäste
vermieten oder weiterverkaufen.
So ihre Geschäftsidee.
Eine solche Box wäre cool fürs Sofa.
Man könnte das Sofa
darum herum platzieren
und auf der Box Getränke abstellen.
Das wäre richtig stylish.
Alte Sachen
sind Melanies Leidenschaft.
Neben ihrer Tätigkeit
als selbstständige Coiffeuse
verkaufte sie Shabby-Chic-Möbel.
Mario hat einen Kaderjob
und verdient damit
den Grossteil des Familieneinkommens.
Das Einzige, was uns bzw. v.a. mir
ein bisschen Angst macht,
ist das Finanzielle,
dass die Rechnung Ende Monat aufgeht
und im besten Fall
etwas übrig bleibt.
Dort drüben gibt es ja
keine Pensionskasse, keine AHV etc.
Man muss selbst Geld beiseitelegen.
Trotz der Unsicherheit:
Der Plan zum Auswandern steht.
(Übers Mikrofon)
Oldsmobile, 6,5 l, V8.
Wir haben viel Liebe und Geld
investiert,
aber jetzt verkaufen wir ihn.
Ihr kriegt ein ganz besonderes Auto,
wenn ihr es kauft.
(Mann) Minus eine Lampe.
Die müssen wir nicht mitnehmen.
Ist das der von zu Hause?
Nein, den habe ich
auch noch gemacht.
Hast du noch mehr?
- Mhm.- Und das hier?
Das sind alles Rohlinge.
Sie sind noch nicht ganz fertig.
In Wolfenschiessen
im Kanton Nidwalden
bereiten sich zwei andere Auswanderer
auf ihr Abenteuer vor:
Steff Felix und seine zukünftige Frau
Isabelle Schelling.
* Lauter Sägelärm *
Jetzt so.
Die beiden
verpacken Steffs Werkstatt.
Hier widmete sich Steff seinem Hobby,
der Holzschnitzerei.
So, wieder eine Kiste. Anschreiben.
Gut.
- Eine kleine Werkzeugkiste.
Ja, genau, Kleinkram, was?
- Mhm.
Isabelle und Steff
wollen nach Island.
"Tools."
Das Ganze
begann mit der Seniorenreise.
Ja, genau.
Wir buchten eine Pauschalreise
über Lidl oder ALDI.
Und ...- Wir sassen mit
lauter alten Leuten in einem Car.
Wenn sie ausstiegen,
um sich einen Wasserfall anzusehen,
waren sie nach 10 m total kaputt.
Wir kletterten wie Gämsen
überall herum und machten Fotos.
Danach hatten wir
glücklicherweise zwei Tage frei
und konnten ein Auto mieten.
Wir zogen auf eigene Faust los
und erkundeten
so viel wie möglich von der Insel.
Es ergab sich so, dass wir immer
wieder nach Island zurückkehrten.
Und eigentlich kam deshalb
nur dieses Land
für eine Auswanderung infrage.
In Island
wollen sie Tiny-Häuser bauen
und diese an Touristen vermieten.
Kriegst du sie
noch hier hinten rein?
So oder umgekehrt?
- Das ist egal.
Gib mal her. So.
Wir erhoffen uns ...
... ein anderes Klima und etwas
mehr Distanz zu den vielen Menschen.
Hier sitzt man so eng aufeinander
und beobachtet
einander dauernd gegenseitig.
Wir wünschen uns einfach
etwas mehr Luft.
Und ...- Und wir wollen
ein eigenes Projekt starten.
Wir wollen uns den Traum erfüllen,
gemeinsam etwas aufbauen zu können.
Einen Traum starten.
Mit Häusern kennt sich Isabelle aus.
Seit über 20 Jahren arbeitet sie
in der Immobilienbranche.
Steff ist gelernter Steinmetz.
Sein Geld verdiente er jedoch
v.a. als Eventmanager.
Ihre Jobs haben sie gekündigt, der
letzte Arbeitstag liegt hinter ihnen.
Alles geht nur noch in eine Richtung:
nach Island.
Auch ihr grosses Haus in Hergiswil
hat schon einen Käufer.
Danke.
Hat er uns die Pläne geschickt?
Ja.
Warte.
- Ah, hier.- Genau.
Für den Bau der Tiny-Häuser
wollten sie einen Generalunternehmer
aus Österreich beauftragen.
So der Plan.
Doch jetzt ist alles anders.
Eigentlich
wären wir heute in Österreich,
um den Vertrag für die ersten
drei Häuser zu unterschreiben.
Und um den Innenausbau auszuwählen.
Eigentlich wäre das alles
für heute ...
... geplant gewesen.
Vor drei bzw. vier Tagen
erhielten wir eine Absage.
Er hat das Baumaterial aus Russland
nicht erhalten.- Mhm.
Er hat kein Holz
und daher ist das Projekt für ihn
momentan nicht durchführbar.
Das Problem ist,
dass wir die Baueingabe in Island
für diese Häuser gemacht haben.
Wir können kein anderes Haus bauen.
Sonst müssten wir
wieder bei null beginnen.
* Melancholische Klavierklänge *
Wochenlang hatten sie
verschiedene Haustypen begutachtet
und Anbieter verglichen.
Mit der Firma in Österreich
glaubten sie,
den passenden Partner
gefunden zu haben.
Durch die Absage
droht alles zu platzen.
Ähm, ja ...
Im ersten Moment dachten wir:
"Das darf nicht wahr sein."
Im ersten Moment
war da einfach eine Leere
und wir benötigten einen Augenblick,
um es zu verdauen.
Es betrifft die Existenz,
die wir aufbauen wollen.
Es ist für den Aufbau
unserer Existenz matchentscheidend.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Hochdorf im Kanton Luzern.
Es ist kurz vor Mittag.
In wenigen Stunden
wird Filialleiter Otmar Gemperli
diesen Arbeitsplatz
ein für allemal verlassen.
Der letzte Arbeitstag.
Es ist sehr seltsam und
ich kann es noch fast nicht glauben.
Der letzte ...
Ich erledige noch alles
und mache dann zu Hause weiter.
Otmar zieht es nach Mallorca. Dort
möchte er ein Restaurant übernehmen.
Die Verträge dafür sind bereits
gemacht. In vier Tagen geht es los.
Denner Hochdorf, Otmar Gemperli.
Vom Supermarkt im Luzerner Seetal zum
eigenen Restaurant auf den Balearen.
Mit 18 war ich mit meiner Mutter
zum ersten Mal auf Mallorca.
Seither bin ich drei- oder viermal
pro Jahr auf Mallorca
und habe die ganze Insel erkundet,
bis ich meinen bzw. unseren
Lieblingsort fand.
Mein Partner und ich
haben uns in diesen Ort verliebt
und wollen dort
ein neues Leben beginnen.
Ich sammelte in der Schweiz bereits
15 Jahre Gastronomieerfahrung,
mit meiner damaligen Partnerin.
Sie ging immer sehr gern
mit mir dorthin in die Ferien,
aber dort zu leben
und ein Geschäft zu betreiben,
konnte sie sich nie vorstellen.
Ich wollte meinen Traum jedoch nicht
loslassen und will ihn nun leben.
* Muntere Musik *
Noch ein letztes Mal
frische Ware bestellen.
Dann ist Feierabend.
* Muntere, mediterrane Musik *
Zu Hause in Emmenbrücke. Otmar
wohnt in einer 4-1/2-Zimmerwohnung.
Zusammen mit Mini-Chihuahua Ronaldo
und Partner Gabor Balogh.
Alles gut?
- Ja, danke. Bei dir auch?- Ja.
* Bellen *
Konntest du alles erledigen?
- Ja.
Sind deine Reisepapiere auch bereit,
Ronaldo?
Am Montag kann ich sie abholen.
- Damit du auch reisen kannst.
Ja, Schätzchen.
Gabor kommt aus Ungarn. Seit sieben
Jahren ist er mit Otmar zusammen.
Auf Mallorca werden sie
nicht nur zusammenleben,
sondern auch gemeinsam arbeiten -
in Otmars Lokal.
Morgen schon kommt der Zügelwagen.
Schon voll, Mamma mia.
Nimmst du für die Reise
einen Koffer oder eine Tasche?
Ich nehme nur
meine Gucci-Tasche mit.
Ich nehme die schwarze.
Die ist kleiner.
Otmars Traum stimmt für mich auch.
Ich träumte auch immer davon,
an einem Ort zu leben,
an dem es einen Strand und Wasser
gibt - auf einer kleinen Insel.
Mich freut es auch, dass wir uns ein
eigenes Geschäft aufbauen können.
Das passt total.
Oh, mein Gott, so viele Dinge.
Hier hatten wir alles,
waren jedoch trotzdem
nicht glücklich und zufrieden.
Ich möchte wieder
selbstständig einen Betrieb führen,
obwohl ich weiss, was es heisst,
selbstständig zu sein.
Aber in den 15 Jahren,
in denen ich selbstständig war,
war ich viel zufriedener.
Nun hoffen wir, dass wir das
gefunden haben, was wir suchten.
Für den Traum vom Leben im Süden
muss Otmar
Abschied nehmen von Emmenbrücke -
dem Ort seiner Kindheit.
Unsere Familie hat ein Gästebuch
für das Restaurant gestaltet,
das wir übernehmen werden.
* Bellen *
Das Ziel wäre, dass dieses Album
von den Gästen weitergeführt wird,
die zu uns kommen.
Das ist eine total schöne Idee.
Otmar weiss schon genau,
wie er sein künftiges Restaurant
auf Mallorca gestalten will.
Wir bringen unseren Touch hinein
und modernisieren es etwas.
Das Braune wird goldfarbig.
Das sorgt für einen gewissen Akzent.
Die Bar
wird mit Goldlack gestrichen.
Den hinteren Bereich
möbeln wir auch auf,
damit er attraktiver wird.
Die jetzige Besitzerin
hilft auch mit
und auch das Personal,
das bereits auf der Insel ist,
wird uns unterstützen.
Ich gehe voll auf Risiko.
Ich investiere wirklich alles,
was ich habe, in dieses Projekt.
Das ist wirklich nicht ohne.
* Entspannte, mediterrane Klänge *
Hier ist die Trafostation.
Der Strom
stammt von der Turbine dort drüben.
Hier wird er gleich aufs Mittel-
spannungsnetz hochtransformiert.
Die Dorfkorporation Azmoos ist der
Arbeitsplatz von Auswanderer Mario.
Als technischer Leiter ist er
Chef von rund 20 Mitarbeitern.
Heute zeigt er einem Lehrling
und zwei neuen Mitarbeitern
die technischen Anlagen.
Hier ist es genau dasselbe:
350 m3.
Dreieinhalb Jahre ging der gelernte
Elektroinstallateur hier ein und aus.
Das ist nun bald Geschichte.
Es wird schmerzen,
den Schlüssel abzugeben.
Mit dem Schlüssel komme ich
in diese wunderbaren Anlagen rein
und kann
jederzeit zum Rechten sehen.
Wenn ich den Schlüssel abgebe,
ist es endgültig.
Mario möchte raus aus der Routine und
in Florida etwas Eigenes aufbauen.
Ich muss noch
ein bisschen ausmisten.
Die alten Kataloge müssen weg.
Heute ist ja alles digital,
aber man hob sie trotzdem auf.
Ah, schau, das hat Lily Rose gemalt.
Das hat sie schön gemacht.
Das nehmen wir auch mit.
Auf diesem Foto waren wir auch
in den USA, auf St. George Island.
Da war Lily Rose noch ganz klein.
Ich glaube,
das war im Jahr 2017 oder 2018.
Ich weiss es nicht mehr genau.
Auch zu Hause in Gams
stehen die Zeichen auf Abschied.
* Langsame Countryrock-Klänge *
Bevor sie in die weite Welt ziehen,
haben die Tscharners noch einmal
Freunde, Bekannte und Nachbarn
zur Poolparty eingeladen.
Ich bringe die Kaffeemaschine raus.
Dann kann sich jeder Kaffee holen.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Hier noch etwas für die Reise.
- Oh, vielen Dank.
Den Spruch darfst du
erst in Amerika lesen.
Erst dann?
Dort vorn ist das Büffet.
Dort gibt es Essen und Getränke.
Ich wollte dir eines in Pink
mitbringen, aber es gab keine mehr.
Melanies Freundin Andrea hat
zum Abschied ein T-Shirt entworfen.
Jetzt können wir im Team-Look ...
- ... zum Flughafen fahren.
Ja, wir fliegen in diesen T-Shirts.
Ja, nicht wahr?
Wir lernten uns
auf dem Spielplatz kennen,
als wir beide mit dem zweiten Kind
schwanger waren.
Die Kinder verstehen sich total gut
und ... Es ist schon seltsam.
Ja, es ist schon Wehmut vorhanden.
Dann können wir nicht mehr sagen:
"Gehen wir heute
auf den Spielplatz?"
Die Kinder können sich
via FaceTime austauschen.- Genau.
Doch, wir schaffen das.
- Wir schaffen das schon.
"Für ein Abendessen
in eurer neuen Heimat."
So lieb. Hast du gesehen? Dollar.
Ich könnte euch mein Wechselgeld
auch noch geben.- Ungeniert.
Zum Wohl, Armin.
Ja, amerikanisch.
Cervelat, Salat und Bier.
Schweizer Gemütlichkeit
im Kreise von Freunden und Bekannten.
* Jauchzer *
Nicht mehr lange, dann kann
Familie Tscharner zum Baden ins Meer.
* Dynamischer Countryrock *
Am Vierwaldstättersee ist die Suche
nach einer Lösung für die Tiny-Häuser
für einmal Nebensache.
Hallo.
Augen zu.
Das sieht gut aus.
Darf man noch küssen?
Ja, er ist kussecht.
- Kussecht?
Isabelle und Steff
wollen heute heiraten.
Okay, also,
dann werfe ich mich in Schale.
Gut.
- Kommst du mit? Komm.
Ich wollte eigentlich nie heiraten.
Ich sagte immer zu Isa:
"Wenn du mir einen Heiratsantrag
machst, sage ich Nein."
Aber irgendwie ergab es sich
über die Jahre hinweg so.
Irgendwie stimmt es jetzt für mich.
Wie eng willst du es?
Mit Isabelle scheint alles zu passen:
die gemeinsame Begeisterung für
Island, die Lust auf ein Abenteuer
und der Mut, das Projekt
mit den Tiny-Häusern umzusetzen.
Gut sechs Jahre ist es her,
dass sich Isabelle und Steff
über eine Datingplattform
im Internet kennenlernten.
In Island
machte er ihr den Heiratsantrag.
Am Diamond Beach versteckte er
den Verlobungsring in einem Eisblock.
Es war perfekt.
Wir waren ganz allein am Strand.
Es war keine Menschenseele dort.
Am Strand
liegen diese schönen Eisblöcke.
Ich machte Fotos und er sagte:
"Schau, der ist auch schön."
Ich näherte mich dem Eisblock
und sagte:
"Oh, hier hat ja jemand
einen Ring verloren."
Ich begriff es eigentlich
erst danach richtig.
Er hat mich schon sehr überrascht.
Das ist ihm wirklich gelungen.
Einen besseren Ort
hätte er nicht auswählen können.
Dann ist es so weit:
Im Kreis der engsten Freunde
wollen sie sich das Jawort geben.
Herzlich willkommen.
Sind Sie schon ein bisschen nervös?
- Ja.
So langsam kommt die Nervosität.
(Frau) Sie dürfen sich jetzt
als Zeichen Ihrer Verbundenheit
und Ihrer Liebe
gegenseitig die Ringe anstecken.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Danke.
Jetzt darfst du mich bereits das
erste Mal über die Schwelle tragen.
Achtung, dein Kopf.
- Ja.- So.
Ich lasse mich überraschen.
Ich weiss nicht, wo es hingeht.
Hast du keine Ahnung?
- Nein.
Eine Überraschung: von Steff
für Isabelle als Hochzeitsgeschenk.
Fliegen wir?
- Ja.
Mit dem hier?
- Nein, mit dem Helikopter.
* Isabelle lacht glücklich. *
Frisch vermählt
zum Rundflug über die alte Heimat.
Ready for take-off.
- Ready for take-off.
(Pilot) Routing: after Bürgenstock
Hergiswil, Alpnach airfield.
Sehr schön. Wow, schau mal.
Wow, schön.
- Oh!
Wollt ihr die Schweiz
wirklich verlassen? Schaut euch um.
Wir verlassen die Schweiz nicht,
weil sie uns nicht gefällt.
Es ist keine Flucht.
- Nein.
So viel Natur um sich herum zu
haben, ist eine Gelegenheit, die ...
Das kann man sich fast nicht kaufen.
- Ja.
Das ist einfach ein Glück.
Danke, Schatz.
Juhu!
Achtung, er kommt zurück.
(Alle, lang gezogen) Ho-oi!
Wie heisst es auf Isländisch?
- Skál.
Auch Skál?
(Alle, lang gezogen) Skál!
Früh am Morgen in Emmenbrücke.
Schatz?
Können wir kurz schauen, welche
Jacke du auf der Reise anziehst?
Dann können wir
die Schachteln schliessen.
Also, die kannst du schon einpacken.
Pullover hast du auch?
- Ja, Pullover habe ich.
Zügelunternehmer Alex
soll das Hab und Gut der Auswanderer
nach Mallorca bringen.
Diese zwei kleinen Möbel
kommen noch mit. Ronaldo!
Die Matratze nicht.
- Jawohl.
Ich muss die Elemente rausnehmen.
- Das mache ich nachher.
Die Tablare nehmen wir auch raus.
- Ja, okay.
Die Tablare nehmen wir raus.
- Okay.
Gut. Okay.
Ins neue Leben
müssen fast 100 Kisten mit.
Persönliches, aber auch
viel Ausstattung fürs Restaurant.
Ich habe nicht so gut geschlafen.
Mir ging vieles durch den Kopf,
z.B. ob wir alles erledigt haben.
Ich schlief etwa 2-3 Std.
Dann war ich bereits wieder wach.
Der Umzug und der Schritt ins
Ungewisse scheinen Otmar zu belasten.
Wehmut macht sich breit,
jetzt, wo es losgeht.
Kleben wir die Türen nicht zu?
Nein, ich nehme noch
die Tablare raus.
Ah, machen wir alles ...
Ronaldo, willst du auch mithelfen?
Hm? Was machst du? Ja.
* Ronaldo grummelt. *
Der Wagen muss
unbedingt beim DJ-Zeug sein,
damit wir es wieder
so ausladen können.
Ja.
Ich bin nebenbei noch Schlager-DJ.
Ich lege
an verschiedenen Anlässen auf:
deutsche Schlager,
Schweizer Schlager,
Partymusik, Ballermann-Musik.
Gabor wandert schon
zum dritten Mal aus.
Bevor er wegen Otmar
in die Schweiz kam,
hatte er in einem Hotel in England
gearbeitet.
Gabor?
- Ja?
Kannst du mir helfen, bitte?
Soll das noch raus?
- Ja.
Sag Alex, dass ein Bildschirm
drin ist. Er muss aufpassen.
Ist der Computer auch hier drin?
- Ja.
Der 20 Jahre ältere Otmar ist
der Planer. Gabor hilft, wo er kann.
Er hilft auch mit,
aber man muss es ihm immer sagen.
Man muss sagen: "Komm, mach."
Dann macht er es.
Ja?
- Du, ja. Komm, helfen.
Ähm, Schatz,
wo hast du deine Hausschlüssel?
Ich muss sie nachher suchen.
- Jetzt, bitte. Ich brauche sie.
Otmar muss die Schlüssel
morgen an den Vermieter zurückgeben.
Vielleicht haben wir sie eingepackt.
* Hektische Trommelklänge *
Ich weiss es nicht.
- Nein, bitte!
Schatz, vielleicht haben wir sie
in eine Kiste gepackt.
Ich weiss es nicht mehr.
Fast alle Kisten
sind schon im Lastwagen.
Aber wo ist der Schlüssel?
* Hektische Trommelklänge *
Doch dann:
In der Schmutzwäsche wird er fündig.
Oh, zum Glück. Danke.
Sonst hätten wir Pech gehabt, nicht?
- Mhm.
Der Zügelwagen ist bis auf den
letzten Quadratzentimeter gefüllt.
Wir haben es geschafft.
All unsere Sachen sind dort drin.
- Ja.
Gute Reise.
- Mhm.
In wenigen Tagen
wollen sie den Transporter
auf Mallorca in Empfang nehmen.
(Lachend) Grüezi wohl.
Auch bei Familie Tscharner
ist es so weit.
Die engsten Freunde sind mit
ihren Kindern zum Flughafen gekommen.
Mal sehen, ob wir
dort drüben einchecken können.
Du hast länger geschlafen als ich.
Mama hat nur 4 Std. geschlafen.
Und du?
Ich bin aber noch müde.
- Du kannst im Flugzeug schlafen.
In wenigen Stunden fliegen sie ab -
nach Tampa in Florida.
Achtung.
Sechsmal schon waren sie
in den USA in den Ferien.
Diesmal gehen sie für immer.
Ich habe am meisten Mühe wegen
der Kinder, obwohl alle sagen,
dass sich die Kinder schneller
daran gewöhnen werden als wir.
Das wird vermutlich so sein,
aber zurzeit fühle ich mich,
als würde ich ihnen ihr Zuhause
und ihre Freunde wegnehmen.
Es ist schon
etwas Herzschmerz dabei.
Sie fliegen einmal
quer über den Atlantik.
(Lachend) Hast du
noch mehr Taschentücher?
Ich habe vorgesorgt.
- Ich habe sie vergessen.
Ich wollte eigentlich noch
wasserfeste Mascara kaufen.
Danke.
* Sanfte, melancholische Klänge *
Tschau, macht es gut.
Gut 8'000 km
trennen Familie Tscharner bald
von der Heimat und ihren Freunden.
Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
* Sanfte, melancholische Klänge *
Ist alles okay, Schatz?
Ich bin so traurig.
Ich weiss, Mama ist auch
etwas traurig. Das ist normal.
Nicht wahr?
- Bereit?
Ja.
Jetzt ist es ernst.
Das ist das letzte Mal.
Wenn wir sie zuvor sahen,
dachten wir immer:
"Wir werden sie ja nochmals sehen."
Jetzt
ist es wirklich das letzte Mal.
* Sanfte, melancholische Klänge *
Los geht's.
- Los geht's.
Tschüss.
- Tschau miteinander.
Tschau miteinander.
- Tschüss.
Hier, schau.
* Sanfte, melancholische Klänge *
* Sanfte Countryrock-Klänge *
Die Forgotten Coast -
ein weitgehend unberührter Küsten-
abschnitt im Nordwesten Floridas.
Vor neun Jahren haben die Tscharners
diese Region
auf einem Roadtrip für sich entdeckt.
Schaut,
jetzt fahren wir über die Brücke.
Nach einer Nacht im Hotel in Tampa
sind die Tscharners unterwegs
zu ihrem neuen Zuhause.
Dort ist ein Delfin.
Dort hinten ist er aufgetaucht.
- Tatsächlich?
Jetzt nochmals.
Yeah!
Ich freue mich,
wieder nach Hause zu kommen.
Ja, wir werden alles einrichten,
ausladen und den Grill anschmeissen.
Es ist schön, wieder
nach Hause zu kommen, nicht wahr?
Juhu!
Jetzt sind wir gleich dort.
Dieses Mobile Home
ist für den Anfang ihr Daheim.
Vor ein paar Monaten erst
haben sie es gekauft.
So.
- So, jetzt sind wir da.
Ja!
- Aussteigen.
Schau, das Planschbecken
ist auch noch da.
Die Muscheln ...
Oh, schau mal.
- Alles noch da.
Die gesammelten Muscheln
sind auch noch da.
Oh!
In den letzten Ferien
haben die Tscharners begonnen,
das Haus zu renovieren.
Ah, ich habe noch
den Passenden gefunden.
Ah, gut.
Das ist schon nicht dasselbe wie
in der Schweiz. Es ist alles locker.
Wer hat hier drinnen
so eine Schweinerei gemacht?
Wie?
- Hier ist ja alles schmutzig.
Was ist schmutzig?
Hä? Woher kommt denn dieser Sand?
Er hat wahrscheinlich ...
Johnny hat doch das Dach repariert.
- Ah, ja.
Wahrscheinlich hat er ...
Oh, damn.
- Was ist? Kein Wasser?
Ja.
- Fliesst kein Wasser?- Nein.
Während ihrer Abwesenheit
waren Handwerker im Haus
und haben das Dach repariert.
Yeah!
- Hei!
Schau mal,
es ist alles noch so, wie es war.
Unser umgebautes Badezimmer.
- Schau, es fliesst kein Wasser.
Scheibenkleister.
Keinesfalls spülen. Dann
reicht es noch für einmal.- Ja.
Mädels, was macht ihr?
- Nicht alles rausreissen.
* Die Kinder lachen. *
Mario ahnt Böses:
Bei ihrem letzten
Aufenthalt hatten sie vergessen,
die Wasserrechnung zu begleichen.
Oh, im Gebüsch
sollte man eigentlich stampfen,
wegen der Schlangen.
Uah! Was ist denn hier alles drin?
Meine Güte.
Doch alles halb so wild.
Nur der Schieber war geschlossen.
Die Zuleitung war abgestellt.
Für den Fachmann kein Problem.
Uah!
- Oh, schau, alles voller Frösche.
Schau mal, süss.
* Sie lacht. *
Ich glaube, die kommen wieder raus.
Hier drin gibt es nichts zu essen.
Es gibt Braunbären, Alligatoren,
weisse Eichhörnchen, Schlangen ...
Ja, also ...
- Schildkröten.
Schildkröten, Delfine ...
Es gibt ganz viele tolle Tiere,
aber auch Tiere,
bei denen man herausfinden muss,
wie man mit ihnen umgeht.
Aber mir macht das
nicht grossartig Angst.
Wenn man den Kindern sagt,
dass sie nicht direkt
ins Gebüsch fassen sollen,
sollte das kein Problem sein.
Schau, Ruby, hinten ist sie türkis.
Deine Lieblingsfarbe ist dazwischen.
So, schau mal. Jetzt essen wir,
damit ihr ins Bett gehen könnt.
Betten bezogen,
Fleisch auf dem Grill und Wasser da:
Die Ankunft im neuen Leben scheint
bei Familie Tscharner geglückt.
Auch Otmar und Gabor
sind inzwischen in
ihrer neuen Heimat Mallorca gelandet.
Hier spricht Otmar.
Tschau, Alex, hallo.
Und sie bekommen schon News
vom Zügelunternehmen.
Dir auch, mach's gut,
tschau-tschau, tschüss.
Mit dem Transport ist alles okay.
Er ist in Barcelona.
Oh, er ist in Barcelona?
Er bucht jetzt die Fähre und
sollte morgen um 7 Uhr hier sein.
Oh, das ist schön.
Die beiden sind unterwegs zu Corinna,
der bisherigen Inhaberin
des Restaurants.
Erster Stock?
- Ja.
Okay.
Hallo.
- Grüsst euch, kommt rein.
Grüsst euch.
- Hallo.
Hallo, Corinna.
Hey. Vor dir brauche ich
keine Angst zu haben, was?
Fürs Erste kommen sie hier unter -
zusammen mit Hund Ronaldo.
Habt ihr schon Hunger?
- Ja, schon ein wenig.
Wir gehen gleich etwas essen.
Ich zeige euch euer Zimmer.
Die Wohnung nutzt Corinna während
der Saison für ihre Angestellten.
Das ist erst mal euer Zimmer,
bis ihr eure Wohnung habt.
Okay.
- Bis dahin könnt ihr hierbleiben.
Das ist doch gut.
- Ja, tipptopp.
Als kleines Willkommensgeschenk
habe ich
ein gastronomisches Wörterbuch
für Deutsch, Spanisch, Englisch,
Französisch und Italienisch
für euch, damit ihr
schon ein bisschen lernen könnt.
Schön.
- Vielen Dank.- Bitte schön.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Der nächste Morgen:
Noch befindet sich der Ferienort
Cala Rajada im Winterschlaf.
Aber schon in wenigen Wochen
kommen die ersten Touristen.
Hallo, Alex, willkommen.
- Hallo.
Mit dem Tageslicht trifft auch
das Hab und Gut der Auswanderer ein.
Hattest du eine gute Fahrt?
- Tipptopp.
Schön, dass du da bist.
Der Plan wäre, dass wir alles
in diesem Bereich abladen
und es dann vorsortieren.
Die Kisten wollen sie vorerst
im Brisas del Mar lagern,
ihrem zukünftigen Restaurant.
Zehn Jahre lang
führte Corinna das Touristenlokal.
Während der nächsten Monate soll sie
es nach und nach an Otmar übergeben.
So haben sie es vereinbart.
Wir bringen die Pflanzen nach unten,
damit wir genug Platz haben.
Wie unten? Nach unten?
- Ja, komm.
Oh, sorry.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt,
was das alles ist.
Otmar wird als Chef
v.a. hinter dem Tresen stehen.
Wo stellen wir das hin? Draussen?
- Stell es mal hier hin.
Gabor, ehemals Krankenpfleger,
Hotel- und Bäckereiangestellter,
soll im Service arbeiten.
Ich hoffe, dass das Restaurant
später auch so voll sein wird -
voller Menschen.
Das hoffe ich auch, ja.
Wir können es hier ...
- In die Ecke?
Obendrauf.
Und dann in die Ecke.
Hallo. Hola, buenas, qué tal?
* Ein Mann spricht spanisch. *
Ah, europastry, vale, vale.
Das ist der Vertreter
von europastry.
Sie haben alles, was Brot betrifft.
Wenn ihr Infos wollt ...
- Hat er einen Katalog?
Online.
- Online, okay.
Todo es online.
Auf der Webseite kann man
auch die Sprache auswählen.
... inglés, portugués, francés ...
Vale, perfecto,
gracias, hasta luego.
Zum Abschied sagt man
anstatt tschüss oft hasta luego.
Hasta lu...- Hasta luego
heisst offiziell bis später.
Aber es wird sehr oft benutzt.
Hasta luego.
Okay, das kommt schon noch.
Muchos trabajo.
- Mucho trabajo.
Ja.
* Entspannte, mediterrane Musik *
Fertig Hochzeit - zurück
auf dem harten Boden der Realität.
Isabelle und ihr Mann Steff
sind unterwegs ins Bernbiet.
Trotz intensiver Suche haben sie
immer noch niemanden gefunden,
der ihnen die Tiny-Häuser für Island
produzieren
und auch dort aufbauen kann.
Wir fanden in Litauen jemanden,
der sie für uns produzieren
und verschiffen,
aber nicht aufbauen würde.
Das wollen wir nicht.
Wir wollen jemanden finden,
der sie für uns aufbaut.
Heute Nachmittag haben wir
einen Termin mit jemandem,
der Interesse daran hätte,
sie zu produzieren,
zu verschiffen
und selbst aufzubauen.
Die Frage ist, ob es preislich
einigermassen im Rahmen liegt.
Das ist einer
unserer letzten Notnägel.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Okay?
Durch den Verkauf ihres Hauses
haben sie zwar
ein gutes finanzielles Polster,
trotzdem ist ihr Budget begrenzt.
Guten Tag, Frau Felix.
- Guten Tag, Herr Beer.
Guten Tag, Herr Felix. Herzlich
willkommen in Ostermundigen.
Holzbauer Heinz Beer
hat viel Erfahrung,
seine Arbeit aber auch ihren Preis.
Nun bin ich gespannt,
was Sie alles zu erzählen haben.
Für mich sind
noch einige Fragen offen.
Das grosse Häuschen
würde hier stehen.
Hier führt noch ein Pfad hoch.
Es würde in diesem Bereich stehen.
Die zwei nächsten kleinen
würden hier und hier stehen.
Erstellte der Architekt
bereits einen Situationsplan,
auf dem man sieht,
wo welche Häuschen stehen sollen?
Das haben wir mal ein bisschen ...
Es wäre gut, wenn ich das
massstäblich hätte, damit ...
Es ist nicht massstäblich.
Er braucht das auch nicht.
Isländer benutzen das nicht.
Das ist unglaublich.
- Fast wie im Wallis.- Ja.
Gut, nun müsste ich noch wissen,
was das Angebot
alles beinhalten sollte.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
1 1/2 Std. später:
Ja, ja, du darfst raus. Ja, ja.
(Seufzend) Schwierig.
- Ja.
Es klingt alles gut und schön,
aber letztlich
ist das Finanzielle entscheidend.
Mhm.
- Also ...
Man kann überall ein Haus bauen,
aber ich weiss nicht,
ob er finanziell
wirklich in dem Bereich liegt,
der in unser Budget passt.
Die Chance steht 50:50.
Komm. Komm, wir gehen nach Hause.
Trotz Lichtblick: Isabelle und Steff
müssen weiter bangen.
In der nächsten Folge
von "Auf und davon"
beginnen Gabor und Otmar
mit der Arbeit.
Sie renovieren
zusammen mit Corinna das Restaurant.
Mal gucken, ob das passt.
Im Keller des Lokals jedoch
ist das Chaos grösser als erwartet.
Hier hinten möchten wir
eigentlich ein Büro einrichten,
aber dass das so schlimm ist,
war mir nicht bewusst.
Das ist ...
* Genervtes Geräusch *
Winter anstatt Sommer in Florida.
Wir froren
letzte Nacht ein bisschen.
Familie Tscharner wird
von einem Kälteeinbruch überrascht.
Und hier ist dann ein Feuer?
Äh, ja.
Sie wollen so schnell wie möglich
raus aus ihrem Mobile Home
und machen sich auf Haussuche.
Die Böden sind schon etwas schräg,
nicht?
Das Haus ist halt 130 Jahre alt.
Tschüss.
- Petra.
Und trauriger Abschied
von der Familie in der Schweiz.
Tschüss zusammen.
Mit Sack und Pack brechen
Isabelle und Steff nach Island auf.
Wir gehen nicht in die Ferien,
sondern bleiben. Das ist speziell.
# U sie stige i Flüger, flüge
mit de Vögu furt, chöme nüm meh hei.
# U sie löh hie aues zrugg,
uf de Suechi für nes neus Dahei.
# Sie göh hüt no uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2024
# Uf u dervo, yeah.